Kat Craig: Tamana, welcome.
It's so wonderful to have you here today.
Thank you for joining us.
We're going to be talking
about your directorial feature debut
"In Her Hands."
I can't wait to hear
all about that process
of making such a beautiful film.
But before we start,
can you tell us a little bit
about what it was like
when you were younger in Afghanistan,
what it was like growing up?
Tamana Ayazi: Thank you so much.
It's lovely to be here with you.
Some of the good memories
I have from my childhood
[are] being able to play soccer
on the street with boys, with my friends.
And also I used to have a bike.
I used to go out every evening
with my friends
to bring groceries,
to just go, you know,
spend some time together
and just be there and exist.
KC: And that very active life
has continued for you.
I know that you started making films
at a really young age,
when you were still
in high school, is that right?
TA: Yes, I was in 11th grade
when I started.
I was part of a program
called Citizen Journalism
and Documentary Filmmaking,
and I was representing my hometown,
Mazar, north of Afghanistan.
And that’s how I started making films.
And it was -- we were supposed
to make one documentary,
one short documentary per month
from pre-production to post-production.
And we were very excited about that.
And it opened other doors.
I was able to go to the places
I have never been
and I was able
to meet people, communicate,
listen to them
and try to tell their stories.
KC: Let's talk a little bit
about "In Her Hands."
Can you summarize a little bit
about what the film is about
and why you chose to tell that story?
TA: The film is about a strong woman
who was trying to make a change
in her community.
And like many other Afghans
from my generation,
Zarifa Ghafari was trying
to make a change in her own hometown
of Maidan Shar, Maidan Wardak.
And she was quite famous in Afghanistan,
so I was really curious
to know about her more.
So that's how I visited her.
And then we were trying to make a film
not only about who Zarifa was,
but also the country itself.
So we tried to include other characters
to be able to tell a story of the country,
not only one person.
And the journey of the country
towards 2021.
(Video) Zarifa Ghafari:
In the name of Allah. May God protect us.
Driver: I’m Mayor Zarifa Ghafari’s driver,
and I guard her 24/7.
And I'm very happy
to be serving a woman
who so completely serves her country
and her people.
ZG: After we pass these deserts,
we’ll feel safer.
Slow down. Drive slowly.
Cars are heading towards us.
(Horn blares)
Driver: I drive above the speed limit,
one hand on the steering wheel,
one on my pistol,
because the road
I drive Zarifa on every day
between Kabul and Maidan Shar
is controlled by the Taliban.
She is a champion for me and our people.
I live every second of my life
with the memory of her.
KC: So the film spans a period --
I think you started
working on the project in 2020
and Zarifa, the main character,
is the youngest female mayor
in Afghanistan,
in the capital city of a province
that has always had
a strong Taliban presence.
And you did go out and you filmed
in the mountains with the Taliban.
You said earlier that one
of your favorite parts of filmmaking
is talking with people
and telling their stories.
It must have been difficult meeting people
whose views you don't share.
Tell us a little bit about how you managed
to build those relationships
and how you were able to film there.
TA: I think filmmaking and storytelling
is more about listening to people,
understanding them,
no matter how different they are.
So this is how --
When we started working
on this documentary, "In Her Hands,"
that's how it started.
So with Zarifa, for me, it was easier
because she was a woman,
she was from my own generation
and we were trying
to make a change in our communities,
using different tools or different ways.
But then also we thought that's important
to include also the Taliban,
because there was peace talks going on
between the US government and the Taliban,
but Afghans were not included.
And we, as Afghan woman,
knew that we will be
more affected than anyone
if there is any change in the country,
especially if Taliban
will come back to power.
KC: When you met with some
of the senior leadership
in the region of the Taliban,
how did they respond to you?
Were you able to have conversations
and did their opinion of you,
do you think, change
over the course of the filming?
TA: When I first started
contacting the Taliban,
so basically we did it
through the leadership.
We contacted them to be able
to go there and film them.
It took us some time, they did not
respond to messages on time.
So it took us weeks and months
to get permission.
But then once I was there,
because I was a woman,
and then after --
they said after 25 or more years,
there was an Afghan filmmaker,
a woman on the mountains with them.
So they were quite shocked
to see me there.
So when I was doing the first interview,
they tried to not look at me.
But then I remember
by the time they started,
you know, being more comfortable.
And then at the end,
I remember when I was saying goodbye
to one of the leaders,
one of the commanders,
he was blushing and he wanted
to shake hands with me.
And then that time I wasn't sure.
I was like, what will happen?
Because I see all these other
Taliban commanders and Taliban soldiers,
and they had their guns with them.
So I was like, what if I shake hands
and something happens to me?
And I remember our local producer
who visited Taliban so many times before,
he kept saying, "Tamana,
be careful, don't do that."
So, yeah.
KC: And did you shake his hand?
TA: He didn't want to do that at the end.
So yeah, we left at that.
KC: Yeah.
(Video) Solider 1: The government
has failed the people of Afghanistan.
Ask the people here whether the government
has done anything for them.
Solider 2: We are from this country,
and we will serve it.
Solider 3: Brave Mujahideen!
Solider 4: Until we establish Islamic rule
across the whole planet,
we will not surrender to anyone.
I have been put here to fight people.
I have been instructed to kill people.
To destroy people, behead people.
Until they believe
there is no god but Allah.
Musafer: I’ve fought in these mountains
since the US invasion in 2001.
Look at me, I am 36 years old,
but everyone thinks
I am 40 or 50 years old.
KC: This is with the same people who were
sending written death threats to Zarifa,
the main character in the film,
as early as 2017.
Tell us a bit about the risks
that both she and you faced
working in a province that had
such a strong Taliban presence.
TA: It just came back.
I can still feel it.
It was not an easy experience
because you know that any moment
you might get killed.
And there were times
when we filmed at night,
days and nights in Maidan Wardak,
I was with her
and there was fighting going on
between [the] Afghan army and the Taliban.
And also, whenever we were in the car,
I remember she used to
hold my hand really tight,
saying that “Tamana, what if there is
a sticky bomb in this side of the car
or that side of the car?”
But, you know, when you're going
through so many crises,
you find ways to deal with it.
And then we try to remember
the good things
about, you know, being there.
And then I used to say that,
"Zarifa, we are very close to Kabul."
It happened most of the time on the way
between Maidan Wardak and Kabul.
Or I remember when we were in the city
and we lost a few friends
in Taliban sticky bombs explosions.
And we were down most of the time,
but that doesn’t mean
that there was no life.
We found ways to deal with it.
We found ways to be happy.
We found ways to find solutions,
at least to raise our voice.
I remember we did campaigns.
We did protests to --
make people, our leaders,
and the world leaders,
listen to what was happening
and what was waiting for us in the future.
But unfortunately, I think we ended up
where none of us were ready.
(Video) ZG: Whenever I meet people
from different communities,
I ask them to educate their children
because education is the only way out
of this situation in Afghanistan.
Hello, how are you? Are you well?
We thank you for coming here.
Thank you.
Our girls do study. There...
There are some classes.
ZG: As a girl, I studied.
I have a bachelor’s and a master’s degree.
When I was studying, I had to walk
an hour each way to my school in Paktika.
There were many
suicide attacks and fights.
My father told me not to go anymore.
So I started going to school secretly.
I was going to school in secret
after he went to the office.
It was my lifetime dream
to see that my parents are proud
of my reputation and my achievements.
So please educate your daughters
and send them to school.
If you educate one girl or woman,
you save ten generations.
KC: You spoke about
how many women in Afghanistan
were actively campaigning
to continue to move forward
and not to fall back into old ways.
As the filming progressed and you realized
that the Taliban were gaining power
and more likely to come back
to a position of strength,
how did that feel for you and Zarifa?
Did it change when you were
in villages and cities?
Could you tell there was
something different in the air?
TA: Whenever I was in Kabul,
I was not able to see the change
because everything was OK.
Everything was alright.
But whenever I went to the villages,
to other provinces ...
And I remember coming back,
I came with a lot of information,
but I was not really able
to tell even my own family.
I didn't want my sisters
to be scared of the future.
I didn't want my mother to be scared
of her future and my future.
And if I have told them that,
OK, I saw that these things
were happening in the provinces,
especially meeting Taliban,
I knew that they were progressing.
And I remember whenever I went
to other provinces in the past,
I wasn't really sure about it
but it was eye-opening
to see all, you know,
the Taliban, people like me,
ordinary Afghans,
all of us, we were trying
to build a country in our own ways,
but ended up destroying the whole country.
And the --
The flags changed when we crossed
from one territory to another territory.
There was a republic flag,
and then there was [a] Taliban flag.
So we knew that there is a difference.
And I remember, Zarifa and I,
and other friends, female friends,
we talked about it a lot.
We were like, we need to push for it.
We need to do something to change it.
We knew, we had the fear in our heart
that Taliban might come back,
but we thought they will be
part of the government.
And the way it happened --
when the government collapsed,
it was not only the government, it was --
the people, full of hopes and dreams.
And the future collapsed in front of us
and we couldn't do anything about it.
We did have fear, but we didn't know
that it would end up the way it did.
KC: And eventually it got so bad
that Zarifa had to leave, she left.
She came back. She had to leave again.
You have had to leave.
And it's something that very few people
have to make those difficult decisions.
It must have taken a lot.
Do you plan to go back if you can?
Would you return?
TA: After Toronto for one week
my heart was really calm
and I was thinking about it,
because since I left Afghanistan,
the fire was there, you know?
And when I left, I left my soul
in Afghanistan with my loved ones,
with my country, with my homeland,
with everything I had and built
for all these years.
The way we left,
we didn’t know that it [would] happen.
And I remember when I left,
I did not say bye to my loved ones.
I still remember my family.
I still remember my friends.
I told them that, you know,
this is not a goodbye.
I cannot say goodbye.
You don't know what will happen.
I will come back.
I will go to the airport.
I don’t know [if] it will happen or not.
I will be back.
And I was making excuses because
I didn't want to leave my country.
That was home. That was everything.
Yeah, I kept my passport.
But yeah, that's what keeps me alive.
And people might have different dreams.
Some people might think that,
OK, I want to travel.
I want to make the best fun,
I want to do this and that.
But my biggest dream
is to go back to Afghanistan
and live the way I used to live.
KC: We all hope that that will happen
sooner rather than later.
But for now, we know that the situation
is very difficult for many women.
You came to Europe
and even here we've spoken
about the everyday sexism
that you experience
and how exhausting it is to educate men
on issues around gender equality.
Are there parallels?
Do you see any opportunities
for us to learn from each other?
Because I know many people
in the audience will feel your pain
and recognize that exhaustion.
How do we learn from each other?
How do we work together
as women globally to create change?
TA: Sexism is everywhere
and we need to come together
to work on it.
But the only thing I would say [is]
that it’s tiring and exhausting,
but we should not give up. We cannot stop.
KC: Absolutely.
TA: So we need to have solidarity,
to work on it together, to push for it.
KC: And hearing stories
like yours, like Zarifa,
there's an amazing line in the documentary
where we follow her
in such extraordinarily
difficult circumstances
and she's constantly under threat.
And she says, "Well, men have had
40-50 years to get this right
and they haven't yet done it right.
So I'm not going to give up."
Is that representative
of the spirits of many women
that you encountered in Afghanistan?
TA: The spirit of almost
all the women I know in my country,
including my grandmother,
my mother, my friends.
All of us.
Because, yeah, war is ugly.
And it was the men who created the war.
It was the men who made peace.
We always pushed for it.
But then there was no space
for us [at] the table,
no matter how hard we pushed for it.
But it doesn't mean
that we give up and it's done.
And we are, you know ...
We made peace with that.
It was the spirit of the whole country.
It still is.
And it is the women who are [the]
resistance in Afghanistan today.
They were protesting in solidarity
with Iranian women in Kabul,
in front of [the] Iranian embassy.
So yeah, I think the future is female.
It's us.
And we are the ones who can make change
because we don't fight.
We don't care about ego.
We care about solutions.
KC: So all of the people listening today,
inspired by your story,
by the strength of women in Afghanistan,
what can we do to support the struggle?
You said solidarity is key to change,
and I couldn't agree more.
How do we work together?
What can we do to keep the plight
of women in Afghanistan in the news
and to make sure
that one day you're able to return
and do the wonderful work
that you've been doing?
TA: I think women in Afghanistan need
solidarity more than anything right now.
I remember I was interviewing
women who were protesting
because I was working on research
for Amnesty International.
And whenever we talked,
I was asking them
why they started protesting
and they said that,
"Tamana, we lost everything we had.
We are not able to work.
We are not able to go out
without a mahram, a man, family member,
and we are not able to move freely,
travel to other provinces,
to countries outside Afghanistan
without a man."
So it means that Taliban do not count
women as humans or equal to men.
So there should be a man
to validate that they exist.
And they say that,
"We lost everything we had.
And that's why we are fighting.
We are not afraid to die,
but it makes us happy
and encourages us
when we see women,
no matter Afghans, non-Afghans
from outside the country,
supporting us.
And that's all we need."
And they were thanking me all the time
for doing the interviews.
And they were like, "You listen to us
and it's important for us."
So there is a need to come together
and support the woman in Afghanistan,
in Iran, or any part of the world,
because all we fight for
is our basic human rights.
I think it's really important
to support the woman in Afghanistan
or any other part of the world
who are fighting for their basic rights.
It's 2022.
I know that women,
we as women, we are political.
Our bodies are political.
Our opinions, whatever we say,
whatever we do is political.
Women get criticized more than men,
and no matter in which field.
And it's really important for all of us,
no matter where in the world,
to support those women
protesting on the streets in Kabul
and other provinces of Afghanistan.
And one of the ways we can do this,
we can open a conversation
about Afghanistan,
so it's on the news again.
So people talk about it
and we don't forget
what's happening there.
I know that I was the lucky one
who is here now, who is able to work.
But I also know
that it was painful to leave.
But for them, because they are fighting,
they need our support, solidarity.
And we need to put pressure
on our governments,
no matter where in the world,
to change the policies,
to put pressure on the Taliban,
to change their policies
and make a change.
KC: I think people can start
by watching "In Her Hands."
It really is a beautiful film.
It's incredibly compelling.
And for me I found
there were threads of hope in there.
So I think watching the film,
understanding this incredible strength
of the women of Afghanistan,
will inspire many, many people.
And hopefully they will step up
and show that solidarity
and continue to raise
awareness of the issue.
You no doubt will continue to do so.
I know you have more films, I think,
that you're hoping to make in the future.
And we're just very, very lucky
to have you, such a wonderful
and compelling storyteller,
to shine a light on this issue
and educate us all
so that we can stand in solidarity.
So thank you.
It's been wonderful
listening to you today.
Thank you, Tamana.
TA: Thank you.